cette annonce faite par la russie qui
pourrait être un tournant dans cette
guerre ans en ukraine le ministère russe
de la défense annonce que les forces
russes se concentreront désormais sur la
libération complète du dombass elena
volochine bonjour vous avez été notre
correspondant en réussi pendant pendant
dix ans comment analyser cette cette
annonce faite par le ministère de la
défense russe aujourd'hui
alors on va essayé de l'expliquer parce
que ça va être un petit peu compliqué le
dombass qu'est ce que c'est d'abord
cette région à l'est de l'ukraine qui
depuis 2014 était donc en guerre avec le
gouvernement central de kiev le
gouvernement pro occidental qui est
arrivé au pouvoir après la révolution
pro-occidentale de maidan en 2014 ce qui
s'est passé à partir de ce moment là
c'est que la russie a commencé à des
stabilisateurs elle a annexé la crimée
et puis elle a déstabilisé la situation
à l'est de l'ukraine jusqu'à créer ces
deux entités séparatistes dit pro-russe
de donetsk et de lougansk ce qui s'est
passé récemment en février lorsque
vladimir poutine a lancé en fin de façon
à vous et son opération quand je dis
enfin parce que jusqu'à présent ils
démentaient le fait que la russie
participé à cette guerre mais le 24
février vladimir poutine a annoncé que
la russie entrée en guerre en ukraine
pour des nazis fier est démilitarisé
l'ukraine cela signifiait que la légende
de la propagande russe et que les nazis
qui aurait pris le pouvoir à maidan en
2014 aurait durant toutes ces années
attaquer et martyrisé et même fait un
génocide contre ses populations du
dombass et que la russie serait là pour
les libérer c'est pour ça que la russie
parle non pas d'occupation mais de
libération de ces territoires alors
lorsque vladimir poutine a attaqué on le
voit en ce moment à l'écran cette carte
a attaqué sur tout le territoire de
l'ukraine on s'est dit mais que veut
donc faire la lumière poutine quand ils
démilitarisé qu'il des nazis est ce qu
il veut prendre toute l'ukraine et on a
un élément de réponse aujourd'hui avec
ce briefing donc du ministère de la
défense russe sur lequel nous ouvrons
notre journal lorsque il s'agissait pour
le général cône a chaîne cov de faire le
bilan de ce un mois d'opération et igor
konachenkov nous dit tous les objectifs
russes ont été atteints nous avons
entièrement anéanti la défense anti
aérienne ukrainienne et donc nous
pouvons nous concentrer à libérer le
dombass nous avions deux options au
départ nous dit le ministère russe de la
défense c'était soit à les libérer
seulement cette région du dombass ou
bien frappé toute l'ukraine nous avons
choisi de frapper toute l'ukraine nous
avons très bien fait parce que si nous
ne l'avions pas fait et bien les
ukrainiens nous aurait empêché d'aller
libérer le dombass qu'est ce que cela
veut dire si on a bien écouté vladimir
poutine au tout début de cette invasion
le 22 février vladimir poutine a dit les
républiques séparatistes de donetsk et
de lougansk ronde et constitution et il
faut respecter ces constitutions ça veut
dire que des constitutions de république
qui n'ont pas été reconnues
internationalement
revendique des frontières qui vont bien
au delà on le voit sur cette carte de
ces républiques séparatistes de donetsk
et de lougansk donc ce sont des grandes
régions de donetsk et de lougansk qui
veulent aujourd'hui être libérées par la
russie donc ça veut dire que ce serait
selon cette hypothèse 1
une occupation à minimal de l'ukraine
par la russie qui se concentrerait
autour de ces république de l'ouganda et
de données est je sais pas s'ils vont
tuer parce que c'est compliqué mais
c'est important de le comprendre ensuite
la question c'est d'abord marioupol
marioupol d'après la propagande de la
télévision russe lorsque on parle de ce
qui se passe en ce moment à marioupol
ils disent déjà marioupol république
populaire de deuil est donc pour la
russie c'est ac marioupol parti voilà
scénario n'est pas négociable c'est pour
ça que les rues sont en train de raser
la ville parce que c'est le seul moyen
qu'ils ont de prendre marioupol c'est de
la réduire en cendres ils n'y arrivent
pas autrement marioupol sera donc
rattachée on peut le dire de façon à peu
près sûr aujourd'hui à cette république
dite populaire de donner ce que la
grande question maintenant c est ce que
les russes et c'était un objectif
militaire pour vladimir poutine
incontestable est-ce qu'ils vont garder
cette jonction avec ces villes notamment
on la voit pas sur cette carte mais de
bedian sq de milito paul et de carson
aussi qui a été en grande partie déjà
prises par les russes pour faire la
jonction avec la crimée annexe et ça
c'est très important et cette région là
elle ne fait pas partie de la république
populaire dite de donetsk donc donc la
grande question c'est en fait la
question finalement c'est de savoir est
ce que vladimir tout nora militairement
les moyens de ses ambitions mais ce qu
on lit entre les lignes de ce communiqué
du ministère russe de la défense c'est
qu'effectivement ce qu'on sait nous
occidentaux c'est que la russie est en
train de patiner de d'avoir des
difficultés militairement et bien voilà
est-ce que ce serait donc le fait que la
russie se replie sur un schéma a minima
qui serait de parce qu'on ne parle pas
aujourd'hui bien dans la peau d'un côté
russe et dans ce briefing du ministère
de la défense de toutes ces régions de
mélie top éléction peut-être parce qu'il
ya un doute sur le fait de est-ce qu'on
va arriver à les garder finalement voilà
et mais en revanche ce qui est certain
c'est que ce qui ne sera peut-être pas
négociable pour les russes cc c'est
toute cette grande région finalement de
données est que cette grande région de
lougansk tel d'ailleurs qu'elle existait
dans les frontières administratives
lorsqu'elle était officiellement en
ukraine et lorsqu'elles sont
officiellement d'ailleurs en ukraine
mais plus pour les russes mais il y à
ses frontières des républiques de deux
nièces des régions de donetsk de
lougansk ukrainienne ensuite
lorsqu'elles ont deux sont devenus des
régions séparatistes et bien étant donné
que les russes n'ont pas réussi à
avancer séparément ces régions étaient
beaucoup plus petite que initialement en
ukraine donc là c'est apparemment le
schéma vers lequel on s'oriente in fine
et in fine et on serait presque rassurés
de se dire que non vladimir poutine ne
pas pas prendre toute l'ukraine et on
était ne prendra pas kiev n'ont donc
c'est vrai que c'est finalement on est
on est dans dans le dans le schéma du du
voile a dû on se contente du dupire kong
qui aurait été qu'on aurait peut-être
pas imaginé
envisageable encore il ya quelques mais
au vu de la frayeur qu'on a eu peut-être
que finalement on irait vers un accord
en sacrifiant en sacrifiant cette ville
martyre est devenu marioupol et cette
partie est de l'ukraine merci pour votre
analyse est elena volochine